The Joe Rogan Experience wasn't you
telling me about the whales that learned
how to Orcas yeah they've learned how to
[__] people's boats up that's that's so
funny to me it's crazy it's kind of
hilarious because because for all these
years we've been mistreating them and
finally they're like enough yeah I'm
gonna start [__] up your boats and
they're real smart creatures oh yeah and
they probably teaching every whale in
the ocean how to do that [__] probably
at least the whale's there I think it's
only one part of the world where this is
happening right now but the problem is
the word gets out yeah they have some
they have those songs they sing and they
they go hundreds of kilometers and they
that's how they tell each other hey we
[__] people up over here did you see
that video that people are in a kayak
and a whale swallows them no these
people are like they're whale watching
and there's a whale down there and the
whale literally swallows the entire
kayak with the people in it so they
weren't good at it and then spits them
out
well I think that's how they were whale
watching look at this literally just
takes the kayak oh wow maybe he's
annoyed with them maybe the maybe The
Kayaks are [__] up their fishing look
at that
bro that [__] just broke your back
California beach oh yeah easily could
snap your legs in half easily could snap
your neck but they don't eat meat right
so no so yeah but I mean just the power
alone how does it know what it's doing
it's not gentle I mean hopefully you can
you still gotta hope it'll spit you up
oh hoping yeah hoping
the same video yeah look at that that's
from a different angle [__] insane
three years ago then did it really yeah
oh no kidding yeah that's weird I'm good
that's weird I'm good I know it went
viral again which has been happening
with quite a few videos so you see all
the fish that's there see how the fish
is in the water flapping around that's
why the birds are there see all that
that's splashing [__] that's fish
so the the whales trying to eat the fish
and these [__] suckers in this do they
survive yeah you spit them out oh lucky
he wanted the fish he didn't want to
kayak but any of them seriously injured
I don't know good question
I don't get it I don't get these I don't
get these people that need to need life
risking uh they don't think it's like
activities
I mean this is this is on the this is in
the top like if if going down to the
bottom of the ocean in a experimental
sub is is number one yeah this is on
that list this is top ten did you see
the guy in the kayak that got attacked
by a tiger shark no no he's in the kayak
rowing and you see this tiger shark just
just engulf half the side shark watching
no he was fishing
watch this
it's like his foot's in the water too
man
right look at this
tiger shark
tiger shark ran me holy
watch this look so his foot
so his foot's in the Water right
that's the paddle is to the left but his
foot was in there too look at that thing
oh so he was like waving it like this
and he thought the shark thought it was
food yeah shark probably thought it was
a seal or some [__] they're not smart
yeah bro I don't get it I don't get this
this desire to Thrill seat look at this
in slow motion look at this thing come
up
[__] hey man
thank God that wasn't inflatable too
whoa
um what did I hear there's a shark [__]
some sharks attacked a boat recently you
know about the dude in Egypt that got
eaten I heard about it it was one of the
bottom of the barrel tops but I didn't
know what the [__]
it was a rough one uh this dude is in
Egypt and he's off the shore Netflix
Crews whole boat exploded after
back-to-back shark attacks in Hawaii
like something out of Jaws oh my God I
think they were filming it so we'll
probably not see it until oh my god oh
our planet too so that would probably be
really good wow yeah I heard like it was
like a Fred out of Jaws it's a little
shark attack a shark attack and then the
boat exploded well he's attacking the
boat yeah like if it exploded like
because the gas then yeah that's right
out of Jaws but as they say an exploded
or are they saying it just fell apart I
think fell apart I think they said a
rubber dinghy can you scroll back down a
little bit in there it says uh Nolan
said the crew was only about 328 feet
from the shore so they're able to make
it safe for the land though barely on
land that they patched up the boat and
deployed a rubber dinghy but that was
attacked by giant trevale's Marine
fishes that can grow up to six feet long
and weigh more than a hundred pounds
that attack knocked out the dinghy's
motor what the [__] man going on over
there the behavior the sharks they
encounter was extremely unusual Nolan
told radio times
they were incredibly hungry so there
might not have been enough natural food
and they were just trying to anything
that came across in the water
wow I said it was just released